the Cambridge Encyclopedia of astronomy  I love this book it was published in  1977 and it's not just a book about  space it's also a piece of music history  ten years before it was published  Jocelyn Bell discovered the first Pulsar  a rapidly spinning neutron star that  emits electromagnetic radiation from its  poles she discovered it because Earth  lies within the path of its beams every  1.3 seconds our planet is bathed in its  radio waves and each pulse is a little  bit different because of random  interference caused by gas and dust  between the pulsar and us to better  understand the Pulsar she found  researchers recorded the strength of  each pulse stacking successive pulses on  top of each other to form an image in  1979 a British rock band found that  image published on page 111 of a copy of  this very book and they decided it would  make a pretty cool cover for their album  Unknown Pleasures by Joy Division